[Music]
bitter sweetness is a view of the world
and a way of being in the world
it's a weighted connection it's a way to
transcendence
[Music]
you're very attuned to the gap between
the world as it is
and the world as we would wish it to be
you can take those pains and
sit with them somehow and then
make meaning out of them
here's a question for you
are you one of those people that finds
soulless that finds comfort in things
like rainy days or melancholy music
if you know what i'm talking about
that feeling isn't really a feeling of
sadness it's more like this feeling of
longing like this
beautiful ache this ache that actually
makes you feel
more connected to the human experience
so
what is that experience exactly well
today's guest former corporate lawyer
turned author
wondered the same thing and so she went
on like this seven year journey to
better understand it the result of which
is bittersweet her number one new york
times best-selling book that ponders
this quiet state of being and why
embracing it pays a true path to things
like creativity deeper connection and
ultimately transcendence
i think you could say that quiet states
of being are susan kane's thing they are
her specialty because her first book was
literally entitled quiet quiet the power
of introverts in a world that can't stop
talking that book spent eight years on
the new york times bestseller list her
writing has appeared everywhere her ted
talks on the power of introverts and
this idea of bittersweetness have been
viewed over 40 million times and today
she's here and no surprise we go deep on
both these things introversion and
bittersweetness
which i think we can agree are both
states that culture doesn't do a great
job of encouraging
and yet both are are very powerful when
recognized and when nourished as these
vehicles for acceptance and for meaning
and for connection
so here we go please hit that subscribe
button and enjoy
me trying to hide just how nervous i was
and a bit intimidated i was
talking to susan kane
i was thinking about you the other day
because
i got invited to attend this conference
down in san diego
and uh i was looking forward to it like
i get to actually just relax and be an
attendee as opposed to getting on stage
yeah which is very to this day anxiety
producing in me and then at the last
minute um it was being put on by sanjay
gupta at cnn and he he texts me and he's
like oh by the way i think it would be
great if you did
like a fireside chat with lance
armstrong like on thursday or whatever
and i immediately went from like
thinking this was a little bit of a mini
vacation
yeah like oh my god how am i going to do
this like tormenting myself and being
tortured
over the whole thing because
no matter how many times i've graced the
stage it still feels very unnatural to
me and is still very anxiety producing
yeah i know exactly what you're talking
about
um
it's like
i mean you
you probably know i used to have this
huge public speaking phobia so for me it
used to be like you know a completely
destabilizing event so i'm totally past
that now like that's overcome
but i still completely relate to what
you just said like if i'm in the
audience and going to the conference
like
lala right but
waking up in the morning when i have to
be the one on stage it's just like
that's not a chill morning yeah yeah
well the occasion of this conversation
is your your latest book bittersweet but
i do want to spend a little bit of time
on the introversion
matter yeah um because i relate to it so
deeply as somebody who has come into an
awareness of being
um you know an introvert or on the
introversion side of that spectrum yeah
yeah but somebody who can uh emulate the
extrovert for short bursts or periods of
time
but always has to retreat to you know
charge the battery back right yeah we
should definitely talk about that oh
yeah i know i get it completely yeah so
i'm just i'm interested in how you it
you know it's so interwoven with this
the public speaking thing too it is so
interesting yeah i think for many well
not for every introvert because there
are introverts who are totally
comfortable with public speaking it's
like some small subset of them feel that
way but for most people they more
describe what you just did yeah
but even extroverts probably fear it on
some level is that the case oh lots of
extroverts fear it yeah i mean it's like
the number one fear so there's tons of
extroverts who are terrified of speaking
yeah and yeah you know what's
interesting about your work
um you know when we talk about quiet and
introversion
which is a subset of the population
albeit a larger one than i think we
previously realized
bittersweet uh speaks to something
that's universal in all of us not just
to that subset but on some level to
everybody
but i think what unites these books or
one thing that unites them
is is that
they both are this call to elevate
something that society
undervalues or doesn't quite understand
and often or or you know to our
detriment squashes out of us yeah so
that's kind of you know this
universality theme that permeates your
books like how does that like what is
that sensibility like how did you come
into that i'm interested in like how you
chose this subject matter and and why
this has become you know your your
calling yeah absolutely we can talk
about that um i think about it also it's
exactly what you just said like hidden
superpowers um and it's also about a
different way of being in the world from
the one
that is celebrated you know in the media
in celebrity culture and all of it
in our work culture
i would say both of the books are about
a different way of being in the world
i mean i'm just interested in in the
genesis of all of this for you i know
it's interwoven with public speaking and
maybe we can begin with the introversion
question like
this appreciation of introversion in
yourself and this kind of quest or
desire to dig deeper into what that
means and how
what you discovered could be healing to
the many many people who are introverts
and feel out of step with
cultural expectations or a sense of who
they feel like they should be or could
be
yeah i you know i don't know where this
comes from in me but i would say
when i wrote quiet and when i wrote
bittersweet i thought that i was writing
two really different books
um but now when i look at them
they they both have to do with the way
in which
um
society has
culture has such a
specific and really rather narrow
expectation of the way that we're
supposed to be in the world
and so both books are talking about a
different way of being and one that is
quite powerful or ways that are quite
powerful in their own right
um
but that don't get celebrated and you
know and kids from a very young age like
in the case of introversion or are
taught you should be you know out there
you should be dominant you should be um
loud you should be take charge you know
this whole constellation
of qualities um which are wonderful but
there's another way of being that
describes a third to a half of the
population
and that brings with it delights and
powers of its own and it just felt to me
like you know a colossal waste of
challenge and energy and happiness to
be telling half up to half the
population
that
you want to be
that who you are isn't okay and you
should be turning yourself into a
pretzel to be some other way right right
and and so how do you define that like
how what is your definition of
introversion and i suppose the follow-up
question of that is like how does that
differentiate from someone who is shy or
somebody who is
insecure or has some kind of social
anxiety
yeah so introversion is about
i mean there's a kind of popular
definition which i think works really
well of like where do you get your
energy from you know and a really easy
way to think of it is to imagine that
you're at a party and you've been there
for about two hours and it's with
company you're truly enjoying and you're
having a good time um but still you know
the extrovert at the party their battery
is
is charging up
and now they want more
whereas an introvert's battery is
probably draining no matter how good a
time they're having and so there comes
that moment where you just wish you
could beam yourself home and be
someplace else
and um
and so it really is this question of
like
you know how much
how much stimulation do you need
in order to feel in a state of peace and
equilibrium you know and for introverts
they get very quickly to a place of too
much
and for an extrovert you get very
quickly to a place of too little you
know like if things are too quiet not
enough is happening you feel like you
know i better call a friend i better do
something right um
and all of that is quite different from
shyness which is more about the fear of
social judgment you know and like
um
a shy person looks at
has an interaction with someone who
might have a neutral expression on their
face and they'll tend to read
disapproval into the neutrality and then
be very upset about the the disapproval
so um
so it's a quite different state like you
could be an introvert and not be shy or
vice versa um
but my work i would say focuses on both
both ways of being because both ways of
being show up very similarly in terms of
behavior and so they get judged in
similar ways right right yeah and and
shyness being something that is mutable
but perhaps introversion or extroversion
is more
fundamental or constitution like is
there immutability to it yeah i don't
know if i'd say that one is more
immutable than the other um i would say
in both cases there are temperaments
that people are born with that
predispose you in one direction or
another
um you know and then layered over the
temperament you have all kinds of life
experiences and skills that you gain and
you know it's all a big mishmash but um
but
there are babies who are born
um
into this world and from the day they're
born you can test their nervous systems
and see that they're more reactive to
all different kinds of stimulation like
they'll they'll salivate more if you
give them sugar water and put it in
their mouths and so the babies who
salivate more when they're two years old
and you put them into a play group of
kids they've never met before
those are the babies who are going to
tense up and
and take longer to integrate into the
group because they basically have a
nervous system
that is just reacting more to new inputs
and it makes you want to like slow
things down and pause and check it all
out before you're ready
is that like when i think about that
the the word that comes to mind is
sensitivity right which is applicable to
to bittersweetness too like i took the i
took your quiz yeah i scored a 7.3 so i
guess i'm
prone to some level but bittersweetness
but i've always thought of myself as
maybe just a little bit more sensitive
than certain other people
and sensitivity could be a word that you
could apply to introversion as well like
they're just more sensitized to their
environment or i mean how do you like is
that a completely different way of
thinking about this or how does that no
it's more like these are all
really overlapping categories they don't
lay totally on top of each other but
they overlap so with bittersweetness um
which by the way i define as a kind of
a state of mind where
you're very attuned to
the way in which joy and sorrow in this
world
are forever paired you know you don't
get one without the other
in this life
and the way in which
everyone and everything we love will not
be here forever but that somehow what
comes with that
knowledge there comes a kind of deep joy
at the beauty of the world so it's a
it's
a like a real blend of all these
um
deep instincts
and what we found we have a bittersweet
quiz i say we because i developed it
with scott barry kaufman i know you know
and um i'm seeing him on friday night oh
that's right i know i know he actually
was inviting me to come but i'll be back
home by then
um so scott barry kaufman and i and
david yaden who's at johns hopkins uh we
developed this quiz to measure how
bittersweet you are
and what we found is that the people who
score high on the quiz like you
also score high on this trade of high
sensitivity that you're talking about
kind of instinctively and
that trait is basically like
the kind of person who just reacts much
more intensely
to everything you know like if you see
the beauty of the
these canyons out here like
you're gonna really love it um and if
there were suddenly a loud and terrible
noise it would probably bother you that
much more
um
but and so many introverts are highly
sensitive but not all of them so we
actually didn't find that there's any
correlation between bitter sweetness and
introversion that's the correlation is
with sensitivity that's really
interesting yeah because you would think
that they would toggle together
well it's like about 80 of highly
sensitive people are introverts but you
could be highly sensitive and be
extroverted also right and then you can
be introverted and not be sensitive so
that's why i say these are like
overlapping
categories
i'm interested in how we arrived
at this moment
in our culture and you've written about
this
where i wouldn't say we pathologize
introversion but we certainly don't we
don't like socially select for it right
we're
introverts are sort of thought of as
the people who are going to have a
harder time in the workplace achieving
they tend to have more difficulty
getting their ideas across because of
the constructs that we've created around
education and and
and
professional careers and you've written
extensively about like how we've gotten
to this point and how we might rethink
these cultural mores or priorities to
better understand
not just
this dynamic between introversion and
extroversion but also like how to
leverage the beautiful talents of the
introverts so that they can thrive
because
just like extroverts they can become
leaders and they're often the people
with the most interesting creative
forward-thinking ideas
yeah and so there's this real mismatch i
mean when you look at who have been
many of the most creative people over
time i mean like psychologists have
studied this and you usually find people
who
are quite introverted or at least to
some degree introverted because solitude
is such a key ingredient of creativity
which is not something that ever gets
talked about but it's true
um
yeah and for me you know
i am
i think i was just aware of this
mismatch from a really early age because
i come from a family of introverts like
i don't think we have a single extrovert
in my family of origin
and
it was just really plain to me that the
different things that my family members
were doing in the world
things that i admired
were so related to
their kind of quiet and cerebral way of
being you know like i had a father who
um he was a doctor and a medical school
professor and he was amazing at what he
did and he was the one you'd go to if
you couldn't figure out the diagnosis he
might be able to figure it out
and and he was also somebody who would
go to work these long hours and he would
come home after work and pour over
medical journals
um
and
like go to the medical conferences and
sit in the front row and tape everything
and listen to it over and over again
until he'd figured it out
and it was things like that this
that i kept seeing in real life
and then many of the artists i admired
and writers i admired so just like
people out in the world
were so clearly contributing not in
spite of but because of their quieter
way of being
and yet
as you're saying in our schools and in
our workplaces
it's not thought of that way right
and so
what is the
solution for that i know you've you've
done a lot of work around like
reorienting the workplace and trying to
find ways where we can you know foster
you know that type of energy and and
bring it to the surface and in a way
where it is respected
yeah i mean i do think as with
everything that raising awareness is is
the hugest step of all and it's actually
been amazing to see how over the last 10
years how much more
awareness there is and how much of a
shift in orientation um there is you
know so there are lots of workplaces
that are like thinking about this in
really conscious terms and um they work
in groups formed around it and you know
they're thinking through different ways
of hiring and promotion and that kind of
thing um and you also see schools doing
things like
um
like rethinking the way kids are giving
given feedback you know because so many
kids are told
um
you know like sophie is doing great in
class
is doing great academically but she must
learn to speak up more in class
and getting that feedback compared to
sophie is a deep thinker and when she
contributes
everybody turns around to listen because
because she has so many
interesting insights to add right that
feels completely different to sophie and
i've gotten a lot of letters from so the
sophie's of the world telling me
how painful it is to them when they get
the first type of feedback right they
feel like their teachers don't respect
them at all
so i am seeing those kinds of changes we
are seeing those kinds of changes and
that's really gratifying even though i
think we have a long way to go
i just know for myself when i think
about open plan
open floor plan workplaces or you know
co-working play like that just that
sounds terrible to me like i want a womb
i want to shut the door yeah i don't
want any windows i don't want anybody to
ever knock on that door or for the phone
to ring like my great ambition is to be
left alone and when i can inhabit that
place i then can do the work that i feel
compelled to do my best work
but anything that involves collisions or
like inner is like just sounds like a
nightmare to me and when i see that
trend of like these open floor
plans like that doesn't seem conducive
to the introvert like being able to
express themselves optimally oh my god
yes and in fact i discovered this
because um
well you know like you i used to be a
corporate lawyer so i had come from this
world i assume your firm was like this
where you know everyone had their own
little office it was almost like a dorm
room or a dormitory with everybody in
their their office so i kind of thought
that's what work looked like and then i
started researching quiet so i decided i
was going to like plop down in silicon
valley for a while because i figured
there would be many introverts there and
i was expecting this kind of introvert
nirvana
i got there
and all these people who i was
interviewing they're all coming up to me
and kind of whispering like this open
office plan that i'm in
is a disaster i can't concentrate like
everything that you just said
everything's overwhelming everything's
overwhelming and they're like i can't
tell my boss this is why they're
whispering they're like i can't tell my
boss because
if my boss heard me saying this they
would think i'm not a team player they
think i don't like my colleagues and
it's not that it's just everything you
just said you know about
the best way that they would feel would
focus and be in a state of equilibrium
would be in private environments
so
so they started asking me like is there
research that i could show my boss to
just let them rethink this a little bit
and i started looking
and and this was already this was like a
long time ago
but even by then there was a lot of
research there was a mountain of
research showing all the problems with
these open office plans
specifically for introverts but really
for everyone you know focus goes down
people get more sick all this stuff
so
fast forward i would say now people are
starting to understand how problematic
that kind of floor plan is
um and especially now in the wake of the
pandemic
there is a kind of rethinking going on
right where we end up remains to be seen
because it's also much more cost
efficient to have everybody crammed into
a big space so the pandemic must have
provided you with a lot of data on this
like on one level it's sort of nirvana
for the introvert who now can be
ensconced in their own home and can sort
of control their environments a little
bit better but then over time maybe not
so good like what have you learned about
the pandemic in terms of
the introversion extraversion thing in
the workplace etc it's a little bit of a
mixed bag because uh you know
as you're suggesting for there's a way
in which especially during kind of peak
lockdown there's a way in which it was
much easier for your typical introvert
than for your typical extrovert um but
but all the uncertainty that was
involved and the disruption isn't easy
for anyone and introverts in general
have
are less comfortable with uncertainty
than extroverts are so i would say it
took a toll in different kinds of ways
but what i really saw is that
excuse me
especially at that moment it was
it was really a fantastic time
regardless of who you were to take stock
or regardless of your temperament to
take stock of
whether your previous life had been
working for you or not you know because
i yeah i knew many extroverts who were
telling me
you know what even for me i was going to
24 7 and now i realize that i want to
pull this back
um and then there were introverts who
are saying
this is fantastic and i love not having
to go to the office all the time and i
have to rework my life
to
to preserve some of this
yeah i think um
we're going to be learning about this
for years to come like we're still kind
of in it and we don't necessarily have
the the 10 000 foot view on the long
term impact of this but
you know it's been hard for everybody
it's been very hard on you and your
family i know that and must have been
excruciating for you while writing this
book on bitter sweetness to you know
kind of endure loss in your own family
yeah you know that was an interesting
thing because
people assume
that i wrote bittersweet
like in response to
the disruptions and the losses of the
pandemic but
you know because as you say i lost my
brother first and then my father um to
covet
but i was actually working on this book
for years before that you know that is
my way i work on things for a really
long time
so
i don't know what's interesting to me
about that is
i i see the world as bittersweet all the
time like regardless of what's going on
you know so when it's a pandemic it's
not surprising to me and the epigraph of
the book comes from
the leonard cone quote of um there's a
crack and everything and that's where
the light gets in
so
because of seeing the world that way it
means when
when
we're in difficult times
i'm also more apt to be looking for what
the the light side is just as when we're
in good times i'm like come on you guys
don't you realize everything's not as
perfect as you think yeah
there's also all this loss and fragility
going on at every moment um
it's a kind of world view where you're
seeing it all constantly
well it's a non-binary non-dualistic
approach right it's a very holistic
approach to how emotions operate and you
can't have one without the other and
this is a soup and the more that we can
appreciate that one doesn't happen
without the other
the more kind of space there is for for
healing and kind of understanding
the beauty and the power of leaning into
these emotions rather than avoiding them
because we're constantly being signaled
to just be happy or pursue happiness at
all times at all costs right right
um
yeah and in fact i uh
i gave a talk about bittersweetness at
ted the summer before the pandemic hit
so it was the summer of 2019
and it was really interesting because
i felt like there were half the people
like when i came off stage and i knew a
whole bunch of people in the audience
and half of them were like oh my gosh
this is totally me and i totally
understand what you're talking about and
then some of them were like oh i didn't
know that you were depressive
and i was like no that's actually not
what i'm saying at all um
and then and that's part of what the
problem i think with
that our culture
part of the problem that our culture has
is that we don't have a way of
distinguishing between
you know clinical depression which i
would never recommend to anybody
versus
this way of being that takes it all in
um the good and the bad and is just
aware of it all right it's very telling
that somebody would just leap to that
yeah and associate those two things as
being the same and pathologizing it
right oh my i'm sorry something's wrong
with you as opposed to this is life
and of course we aspire to live happy
lives but that happiness is informed by
the you know inevitable
obstacles and painful moments that that
descend upon all of us and the manner in
which we're able to kind of embrace
those moments learn from them lean into
them i think enriches the happier
moments because that's truly how you
appreciate life rather than running away
from those other things and repressing
them and trying to dodge them
yeah and there there's this whole like
if you look at all our wisdom traditions
and our literary and artistic heritage
heritages
across the world across the centuries
like they have been teaching
all this time that this is a way in that
that are preach that appreciating
this side of existence you know the
bittersweet side of existence
is a way to creativity it's a weighted
connection it's a way to transcendence
um
and the way that i got into this whole
inquiry in the first place is because
all my life i had had
this really intense reaction to sad
music um but by intense i don't mean
intensely sad i mean like i'd hear this
music and feel completely uplifted um
so there's this one moment i was in law
school
and some friends were were picking me up
in my law school dorm on the way to
class
and i was blasting leonard cohen or
something um as i am want to do and and
my friends came by and there they
thought it was hilarious and they were
like why are you listening to this
funeral music
and
at the time i just laughed and went to
class
and that was the end of the story
but
i couldn't stop thinking about it
because
it was like well what is it in our
culture that makes it so odd to listen
to this music but even more what is it
that the music is telling us
um
there's something in it
i mean we we know that sad music is much
more likely to produce like goosebumps
and chills and listeners people listen
to the happy songs on their playlist 175
times but they listen to the sad songs
800 times
and and there's something there's
somewhere that that music is pulling us
of like
that the musician is telling you
that thing that you felt you know that
pain that you've sometimes felt
i the musician have been there too and
everybody listening to this has been
there too and we are all connected in
this same strange state of being human
and that's where the feelings of uplift
and love come from right and connection
of course and can you feel like you're
seen and you're being you're being heard
there is somebody else there through a
musical note can identify very
specifically an emotion that you're
experiencing and suddenly you don't feel
alone anymore yeah exactly that's a
joyful experience even if it's
one that also is kind of about sorrow
and pain and grief right because i think
the ultimate human desire is for
connection and that's what it's doing
and so like you look at our culture now
and there's so much divisiveness and so
on and i don't think that's unrelated to
the way in which we're supposed to
present so
cheer so cheerfully and so successfully
all the time
um that means we're not really able to
connect with each other right
right because we're fronting and we're
wearing that mask yeah we're trying to
you know
appear or present in a certain way to be
approved of or to be received in a
manner that you know we would desire
and that ultimately just alienates us
from one another
yeah exactly exactly i tend to look at
these things and i've said this many
times before like as somebody who's been
sober for a long time like through the
lens of recovery
and you know the more that i was reading
your book the more i couldn't help but
think about how this operates in the
12-step context because
you you're part of this community
that has a
you know kind of a shared narrative
about the pain that they've endured and
the struggles that they've you know sort
of overcome to be in this place
uh but then you know somebody has the
courage to get up in front of a group of
people
and share their pain and their grief and
their sorrow but do it with a level of
levity and also a level of of
of specificity and i found the more
specific it is the more universal it is
like
when somebody i may not relate to the
facts of that person's experience but i
can relate to the emotional experience
that they've had and and you can't help
but feel incredibly bonded to this
person and and to the group
through the courage and the pain and the
grief and the levity that makes it all
this you know soupy mess of
emotions
that that just make you feel more human
yeah
um
you know as you were describing that
what came into my mind
is
darwin actually
um because darwin was actually
he was a really kind of gentle and
melancholic type of person like so he's
known for survival of the fittest but he
was actually this guy who like he
couldn't stand the sight of blood his
father wanted him to be a doctor and he
took one look at like what surgery
looked like and you know fled to the
the jungles of the galapagos to look at
beetles
and um
and he noticed
from very early on i mean he was very
aware of how cruel and violent animals
and humans could be with each other but
he also noticed at the same time
that
there's this impulse that mammals and
humans have that when they see another
being in distress that they feel the
distress themselves you know it just
gets mirrored and it's it's happening at
a really like quick and preconscious
level
um
and he thought that that was the
strongest impulse of all in humans
so people talk about how he's known for
survival of the fittest but he could you
could equally talk about survival of the
kindest
and um and now we're seeing
the fruits of that like 150 years later
in the research like there's a guy named
dr keltner at berkeley
who does all this amazing research and
he's found for example that um we all
have a vagus nerve which is the most
important
biggest bundle of nerves in our bodies
regulates breathing and digestion
and your vagus nerve
um
becomes activated when you see like when
you were in your your a.a group and and
seeing somebody talk about their
troubles if you felt that sense of like
your heart opening up or you know your
your throat closing or whatever it is
that's partly your vagus nervous is
becoming activated
almost against your will you know it
just happens
and
yeah and so to cut that off from each
other you know the ability to relate to
each other that way is cutting off one
of our most basic ways of bonding right
so there's there is this implicit like
evolutionary advantage right to
indulging in in in this kind of
emotional
landscape
yeah and i wouldn't call i mean even the
word indulging like
yeah
to allowing exactly i mean it actually
comes from
our need as mammals to be able to take
care of our young you know like you have
to take care of a baby who's crying and
that's how they let you know that they
need something because we're primed to
be able to do that
that kind of radiates outward to our
ability to react to each other in
general in that way and we don't always
get it right but
that is one deep aspect of being human
and the neurochemistry tracks to the
vagus nerve yeah exactly which which
makes me think this is like deeply
primal
dating all the way back exactly exactly
and the vagus nerve is like one of the
most ancient parts of the human body
right so it's it's really fascinating
yeah this idea of of of of
bittersweetness
um
i think most people think of it as an
experience but you talk about it as like
a state of being so distinguish those
two things and how you arrived at that
point of view yeah so i mean it is an
experience in the sense of you know like
the moment where you're walking your
child down the aisle or something
that is a quintessential bittersweet
experience
but there's also a view of the world and
a way of being in the world that's quite
bittersweet um
you could call it melancholic except
that word in our culture is associated
with clinical depression and that's not
really what it means or it's not the way
i'm using it
um
so the bittersweet state of being is
much more about like this sense of
it it's a sense of that awareness of joy
and sorrow and of fragility
um
aristotle two thousand years ago asked
the question
of what he asked this question why is it
that so many of our great poets
philosophers and politicians all have a
melancholic temperament like what is
that
so it's something about being attuned to
the gap between the world
as it is and the world as we would wish
it to be
you know there's like
it's like the emotional dna of humans is
like we come into this world with a
sense that there is a more perfect and
beautiful world that's out there
somewhere to which we belong but we
somehow find ourselves here instead
right so it's not it's it's this the
yearning and the long longing like the
idea that things could be better it's
not a despairing per se but it's a it's
a sense that like we're in a certain
place it could be better and
and the melancholic impulse is built out
of like how to get from one to the other
yeah and it's like it's the heart of our
creative impulse you know it's like a
feeling
of like
how do you get closer to that perfect
and beautiful world
for which you are yearning you know so
that the word longing like it literally
means to grow longer and to reach for
so
there is a sense in which we're all
reaching to get to this other place
and that's what that's what propels us
forward and like historically we've
always known this it's really only
recently that we've forgotten it so like
with the odyssey homer
um that that whole adventure
it starts with homer who's on a beach
weeping for his homeland because he's so
he's so homesick and because he's so
homesick he goes out into the water and
has this adventure
um
it's the same thing with all our
religions you know like we're longing
for the garden of eden we're longing for
mecca we're longing for zion and and all
the religions that like the teaching is
that it's through the longing that you
get closer to the divine itself
so
it's an incredibly generative state
right and it's also
tempora it's about temporality as well
right this idea of fragility and nothing
lasts forever and we're only here for a
short period of time and that ticking
clock you know kind of allah momento
mori yeah yeah is is sort of a driver
behind this state as well absolutely
absolutely i actually tried practicing
memento amore um while i was writing the
book so like my mentomori it basically
means remembering death you know as a
way of like understanding how precious
life is and that idea comes to us from
many different traditions
um so i tried it and i actually found it
to be so incredibly helpful
um
and the place i really noticed it is
like
my kids at the time were pretty little
and we had this bedtime ritual that we
were doing
and
and it was an amazing time of day and it
was like reliably the time that they
would open up about whatever was on
their minds it was just great
um and i also
was bringing my cell phone into the room
while i did that you know while we would
do bedtime
i would say to myself you know
like
they may not be here tomorrow you may
not be here tomorrow you have no idea
and just
that thought
would completely extinguish any desire i
had to look at the cell phone it was
like it was gone and i stopped bringing
it into the room completely
um and it didn't feel
it didn't feel sad it didn't feel
depressing it was just a reminder
right
that
for me
you know connects to gratitude like if i
can be present that's that's the that's
what i'm trying to cultivate it's not
necessarily a bittersweetness other than
like oh my goodness if this is the last
time that i'm able to do this
there's a there's a dusting of sadness
on that i suppose
um it's complicated it's kind of having
to tease all this stuff out no wonder it
took you so long to write this book you
know just trying to wrap my head around
like what it is and what it isn't how
you cultivate it you know how to how to
you know channel it appropriately um
well do you know the feeling i'm talking
about when you listen i don't know what
kind of music you love i mean we all
like many times i mean i love leonard
cohen and i know he's your spirit animal
so he's my spirit i don't know that's
true
yeah no i mean it's just like
yeah
i started out with that question of why
sad music like what's so great about it
and it that seemed like a kind of narrow
question i didn't really realize it was
going to become a whole book um it was
more that that was a gateway question
into this whole
into this whole state
right but if you look at the the
musicians the great poets
the writers all of the you know painters
the ones that seem to resonate the most
are the ones who
are
have the facility to
the capacity to kind of take these
seemingly conflicting emotional states
or the polarities of them and weave them
in some way
that makes sense to us as humans but
perhaps transcends our ability to like
articulate and i think when you see it
it's sort of like when you hear it you
know it when you see it you know it yeah
you're not sure why like why is it that
the the minor key or these certain songs
and the way that they're constructed
um
cultivate that in ourselves i don't know
if there's neurochemistry on that or any
science on that but it really is like i
know what that is i don't know why i
know what that is it makes me feel a
certain way
that is you know perhaps
you know seemingly off my optimal state
and yet
there's a comfort like you talk about
rainy days and things like that like you
kind of want to languish in it
yeah there's a comfort and there's a
there's a transcendence in it with
leonard cohen the very first artistic
act that he took
was when he was nine years old and his
father died
and um
and he he took one of his father's bow
ties and he wrote a poem
and he
buried the bow tie and the poem in the
garden in the backyard garden of their
family house
and that was his first artistic act and
it was like he was kind of repeating
that act again and again throughout his
career
there's a kind of like
taking
something painful and then turning it
into something else
and i think that's like the real
in terms of how to live that's the real
insight that this whole this tradition
gives us because
it's kind of saying to us
these moments are going to come these
pains are going to come
you have two choices of what to do with
them you know you can
suppress it in some way and inevitably
you're going to take it out on yourself
in the form of depression or addiction
or whatever it is or you're going to
take it out on someone else abuse
passive aggression
or
you can take those pains and
sit with them somehow
and then
make meaning out of them and transform
them and that's something that we do so
naturally you know like
like after 9 11
you suddenly see all these people
signing up to be firefighters you know
like the spike of applications it goes
way up um after the pandemic lots of
medical school
and nursing school applications
so
people are like running
you you think they might be running away
from those things that is creating the
pain exactly exactly but it's a way of
of
making sense out of it and making
meaning of it and turning it into
something better and i think that's one
of our fundamental impulses yeah when
we're at our best right like take your
pain and and and transmute it turn it
into a creative offering yeah yeah
and i use the word creative i mean in a
very uh
broad way i don't mean to paint then
spend seven years writing a book it can
be anything right yeah exactly yeah and
that's that's really powerful and i've
thought you know
like that made me reflect on my own life
and realize that without being
consciously aware of it like i've done
that so there is something
instinctual in us that's drawn to that
practice
and um before when when you were still
like before you were in recovery do you
think you were taking the other path or
like
oh i mean before i when i was indulging
in my addiction no i was running away
from everything and repressing all of
those challenging emotions and
medicating myself
essentially
because those emotions were too painful
or i wasn't mature enough to
really you know excavate them
and i was you know at the behest of a of
a powerful substance yeah yeah hijacked
me so right um and i think most
recovering addicts
you know will be able to relate to that
and i think there's something
interesting about the recovery community
and what you kind of learn is that
there's there's something aspirational
there even in the attic like they're
they're looking for
a higher experience of self and
consciousness and they're doing it in a
very self-destructive and unhealthy way
but
at the very core of it is like there
there should be something better or i'm
in pain and i'm reaching
for something else yeah you know and
and then when you get sober and you can
continue to reach in a healthier
direction people in recovery like i know
so many people who are just they're just
amazing human beings because they've
learned to take
that pain
and turn it into some form of creative
offering
that is healing for not only themselves
but for a lot of other people
prophets walk among us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years i've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing
and so i've dedicated my career to
tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why i'm proud to announce the release of
my new book
voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration
and timeless wisdom that transpires each
week on the ritual podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying stand-alone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday prophets
and physically interact with the
life-changing ideas contained within
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
i wrote
most of quiet
in this cafe called doma in greenwich
village
which no longer exists tragically
because it was
it was my place um oh
it was such a great place it was like
it just had this amazing creative energy
and people would come from all over and
and uh
and work on their stuff there and get to
know each other
um
and
every i
i don't know if it was tuesday nights or
thursday nights or whatever but one or
two nights a week
it would happen that this group of
people would come in
and i always noticed them because they
always had like this special
light about them there was a kind of
charisma in them um and then i found out
that they were all coming from an aaa
meeting i'm coming for they're going for
their coffee after the meeting exactly
exactly
yeah yeah they had been meeting like
right down the street
um
there was something about this group
that
you could feel
their reaching you know for
transcendence or reaching for the more
perfect and beautiful world
you could just feel it in their very
being and i think they were probably a
moment in their lives where they were
making the transition from doing that in
an unhealthy way to doing it right in a
meaning-making way right
yeah
one of them one of the more powerful
aspects of that is like making peace
with that pain and and kind of
transcending the shame that's associated
with that and when you can kind of own
it because you've unpacked it and looked
at it and shared it and worked through
it
um that becomes a really
powerful tool for continual growth but
it requires
like taking the blinders off and and
dealing with it and really the subtext
of bittersweet is
is for all of us to do that and
appreciate you know all the colors of
life and to really challenge ourselves
to embrace these difficult emotions
rather than run away from them
and the larger you know the larger
question that i'd love to hear from you
on is like how did we get to
a culture that so forcibly
you know pushes us in the direction of
of you know repressing so much and
start with the calvinists and like walk
us through like how we got to here and
how we can kind of
grow and mature
as a society to have a healthier
relationship with
the nuance and complexity of the human
psyche yeah okay well
um
i'll start with like a glimpse of where
we are right now and then i'm gonna go
back in time so where we are right now
our problem is that we
look at ourselves and each other in
terms of are we winners or are we losers
you know it's like this great binary and
it's a kind of harsh binary and you know
the word loser literally has gone up
astronomically in usage over the past
decades
but going back in time so we started out
as
with calvinism as the dominant religion
and
calvinism the idea was that everybody
was bound for either heaven or hell and
you really had no choice of which
direction you were going in but what you
could do is kind of demonstrate to
yourself and others that you were
heaven-bound and the way that you
demonstrated that was by being a really
hard worker so everything was about you
know labor and hard work um
but then like
in the 19th century that started to
transform as we became more of a
business culture
it became more about like how success
not so much how hard a worker are you
but how successful are you at business
or how much do you fail in business
and then the question starts getting
asked well when you succeed or fail
what is the reason and with these echoes
of calvinism um and barbara ehrenreich
talks about this in in her book really
brilliantly um with these echoes of
calvinism we answer the question by
saying you succeeded or failed because
of something inside you you know it's
like you're heaven bound you're
hellbound you you're either a born
success or a born failure
and
the more
you start looking at things that way and
really believing that the more you need
to develop the emotional affect you know
the emotional self-presentation
of somebody who's a success
so you don't want to talk about anything
that suggests an acquaintance with
longing or
loss or fragility or memento mario like
any of that you're not going to talk
about anything like that you're going to
be presenting in a really cheerful way
and
over the course of the 19th century that
became really
explicit so that people stopped wanting
even to talk about bad weather like that
was seen as not cool
not appropriate to notice that there
were clouds in the sky literally
um and that that's kind of increased
over time so then you get to the
great depression in 1929
and you have all these people who are
losing all their money because of
external forces and some of them are
committing suicide and they're described
as losers um in the journalism
they're described as losers and that's
the heritage that we're still living
with now
um there's i think a deep fear that
people have
of being a loser you know in a deep need
to be a winner instead of like
instead of
seeing the actual truth of the situation
is which is that in all lives there are
successes and failures and wins and
losses and that's just how it is right
it's so interesting that it emanated out
of this heaven hell binary yeah um
winners losers heaven hell
rich for
these binaries that put us in buckets
and allow us to judge each other yeah
and to judge ourselves
to judge ourselves
more detrimentally right yeah i mean the
fear when people start feeling like
they're getting closer to the loser side
of that divide
i think the the fear and the shame and
that is overwhelming
but has that not even expanded because
now as we have moved even more towards
this
um self-help obsessed culture it's a
it's a happy sad thing or a you know
depressed happy thing
and we're afraid of people who are
demonstrating challenging emotions and
we're sort of
repelled by them like we move away from
the person who's grieving or
the person who is depressed because we
don't have a comfort level or a
vocabulary for how to communicate with
them and there's this sense that it's
contagious right like you can't be
associated with that that's got to go
over there and even our relationship
with death to bring momentum orie up
like yeah it's in a hidden corner and we
don't talk about it and we pretend it's
not going to happen to us and
um we've sort of stripped it from our
our kind of daily experience of life
despite its inevitability and there is
something pathological about that oh
yeah and we uh you know we allow people
to grieve for a certain amount of time
but then after that there's something
right yeah it's like really socially
unacceptable that's because it's making
me uncomfortable that you're still
grieving like i don't really want to be
around that
you know i think it's that and i also
think there's something there's a way in
which we judge it you know it's there's
something distasteful about it
i yeah like think of the admiration that
we have for people who
you know they're like moving forward in
a healthy supposedly healthy way like
even in the the most recent version of
the dsm manual for um
in psychology
they've now limited
the amount of time for grieving i'm
forgetting now the exact amount but it's
like a very short amount of time and
then after that you're considered to
have a diagnosis if you're still in a
state of grief for for a loved one right
that's so weird
yeah
and like in bittersweet i tell the story
of
do you know susan david i do i love yeah
yeah so she's a dear friend of mine
she's a great psychologist
and her work came out of
her experience um when she was 14
and
she lost her father to cancer
okay and susan is a really cheerful
person by
temperament that's like who she is um
so because of that
she felt all this cultural pressure and
because she's so cheerful she put on a
big show for the whole year after her
father died she like went to school
acted as if nothing was wrong everyone
would say are you okay she was like sure
i'm fine
but in the meantime she's off in the
bathroom vomiting up her lunch every day
so that's how it was coming out for her
and she would have kept going on that
way
until in her english class she had a
teacher who had also lost a parent at a
young age and the teacher hands out
blank notebooks to the class
and says and and she looks susan
straight in the eyes
and she says
i want you to write down what you're
truly feeling and no one else is going
to read it except me and i'm hardly
going to comment at all but just write
the truth right the truth of your
experiences
and
susan said that moment for her it was
like a revolution in a notebook because
it was like the only time
she had been invited to actually tell
the truth
um
and that was her healing
and like that's what that's what we
don't do right
and that's what leads to this whole
life of exploring emotional resilience
and how to develop it right and
certainly by repressing or running away
from these difficult experiences and
emotions
is to undercut our ability to develop
that level of resilience to weather the
difficult times that we all inevitably
face yeah exactly exactly
yeah and that the more i mean there's
really interesting data on it you know
that the more we have a sense of the
fragility of existence the more of a
sense of gratitude we have um the less
angry we feel
uh the more we invest in meaningful
relationships so
it's uh what i was fascinated by
in the book was you dipping your toe
into the uh sorry i've got a frog in my
throat
into the uh life extension world yeah
you know sort of uh um we're gonna live
forever crowd yeah and i know some of
those people and i'm familiar with that
kind of uh scene so
walk me through that because there is
some there's so many profound
philosophical questions that come up so
many psychological profiles that you
could render about the people who are
obsessed with this that i think are not
getting
an appropriate amount of attention or
discussion
yeah i agree with you and in fact when i
went to one of these conferences i was
just assuming that there was going to be
all kinds of philosophical discussion
about whether this was a good idea or
not or like what the
downside would be pollyanna on that oh
my god no no no it's my yeah i mean it's
much more like
thank goodness everybody here is beyond
all those questions we don't have to
talk about that we know it's a good idea
that's really the vibe yeah
yeah i had um i've had a couple people
on the podcast who are from that world
and i can't help but think like
philosophically like what is your
relationship to life if you could live
for 300 years like how does that change
the choices that you make the risks that
you're willing to incur
and you know the kind of relationships
that you're going to have with people
but that doesn't really seem to be
uh
of interest
i mean
they talk about it but they talk about
it in a way that resolves it very neatly
like they talk about
terror management theory which is
basically um
okay that's the idea
that that
when we are there are all these studies
that show that when we're reminded of
our mortality
that in the immediate aftermath of being
reminded of it we become much more like
focused in our on our in groups and
hostile to out groups
so
there's like studies where they'll
remind people of their mortality and
then ask them how much hot sauce they
want to put on the food that they're
going to give to people in the opposing
political party and people will put on
too much hot sauce um because they they
get into this sort of anti-out group
mode so okay so they take that and they
say well
this means that when we solve the
problem of mortality we're also going to
be solving all our other problems of
conflict and war and everything else
because it's like if we could solve this
we'll solve everything else
and
that's where i feel like i met there's
ways in which i'm actually really
sympathetic to the life extension
project
but
i do feel like it's kind of missing
the
larger point that our problems are not
only about the fact of mortality yeah
the problems are much
deeper than that you know they have to
do with
with just all the longings of existence
that right would be here whether or not
we lived forever depending upon yeah
like they're still they're still there
we're not going to sidestep that and i
think
of course there's something
aspirational about tackling this problem
and it's fascinating to learn about it
and there have been these amazing
breakthroughs in science etc
but i can't help but think
whether or not it's being driven by a
just a deep-seated fear of death
that's so desperate that we must solve
this problem because i don't want to
have to face that myself
well i think they would actually in some
ways agree with that i mean part of the
reason i went to um
when i went to to see them and to study
them was because i was interested just
in this culture that we live in you know
that wants everything
to be like
winning and sunshine all the time and i
thought this would be a really
interesting example of that
but what i actually found is
all the scientists would get up on stage
and present their thing they would begin
their scientific presentation usually by
telling a really heart-rending story of
a person that they had lost in their
lives you know and of how
harrowing and how terrible the
bereavement had been
and and so they were like quite
explicitly saying they were like this is
so terrible you know we just as a
society should not be tolerating
this this deep pain we should be doing
something about it so there was a way in
which i was like really moved because i
felt like they
they were doing their own version of
taking a pain and trying to transform it
into something else
and there there's something else is
immortality itself
um
yeah and what they would say
i think to your point
is well
the the idea that we have that there's a
way in which death or mortality gives us
meaning to life that that's like a nice
story that we tell ourselves because we
have no choice but if we really did have
a choice then we might not be telling
that story anymore right right
um
and i'm not so sure about that
childhood
but it's funny that you say 300 years
because i feel like
you know 300 years that kind of sounds
sort of plausible to me
because if you think about it we used to
only we we would have life expectancies
of 35 or 40. you know now it's 70 or 80
or whatever it is and we're totally
comfortable with having doubled it
so that's different from the achieving
life expect what is it called life
expectancy velocity or escape velocity
yeah what is that longevity philosophy
yeah something like that just basically
every year you live like the science is
extends the ability to extend the life
right proportionately more or whatever
so that by by definition that means you
could potentially live forever
right theoretically yeah yeah
we'll see i don't know
um but on that subject that's not a
distant cousin from this idea of of
transcendence and so i'm interested in
in how this dovetails into
a discussion around um
spirituality and religion these
traditions of religion uh that relate to
bittersweetness that kind of you know
percolate across all these different
variations of of of
of practice i guess
um because that's super interesting
right there is something elegant about
all of this
oh yeah absolutely and i had no idea
when i started off in this path that i
was going to end up writing and thinking
so much about religion
but i started realizing this whole
subject is like intricately bound up
with that because
almost every religion that i see like
especially the mystical sides of of our
religions
they're all talking about this state of
longing that all beings have
for
you know union with the divine
essentially
um and and the idea that the state of
longing is actually healthy in that way
you know like rumi the the 12th century
sufi poet you know he says be thirsty
you know and that the
the the longing you express
well here's this one poem where he's
talking about um about a man who's
praying to god to allah and he doesn't
get an answer back and so he becomes
kind of
bitter and disappointed
and he stops praying
and then um and then he falls into a
sleep and he's not sleeping well
and hitter who's the guide of souls
comes along to him and says why did you
stop praying
and the man says because i never got an
answer
and and
and the guide of souls says to him
the longing that you express that is the
return message
and the grief that you cry out from is
exactly what draws you towards union
and so this is the message that we get
again and again from these traditions
like the grief is what draws you towards
the ultimate love that you seek
and the yearning it's it's like an it's
almost like a
a spiritual or aboris though because
these things are are are a circle
they're a cycle right like the yearning
the the answer that you seek
is in the yearning itself yeah right
yeah
yeah that's really beautiful yeah and i
don't think well i don't know i mean
maybe someone does i wouldn't know but i
i don't know that we ever like actually
get there on this earth but there's
something about the act of the striving
of drawing closer
that
is intensely satisfying yeah
and how did that exploration
land for you as somebody who who kind of
identifies as agnostic but you had this
grandfather who was this beautiful rabbi
yeah where did this lead you
well it was really interesting for me
because i grew yeah my grandfather was
an orthodox rabbi and like i really
adored him everybody did and
he was like such a huge figure in my
life um and at the same time i've always
been deeply agnostic
and didn't really honestly think that
much about religion once i became an
adult you know i was kind of dismissive
of it if anything
but
i don't know i started to realize that
the
the thing that i feel when i listen to
sad music and what someone else might
feel and i do to some extent when i'm in
nature or something like that
the way i see it is that they're all
manifestations of the same
experience and for some people
they have that experience through the
language of the divine and religion and
for others they have it through music or
art or sports or whatever it is but
we're all kind of reaching for that same
state um and in fact there's this
facility parable that i came across
that
talks about
there's a rabbi and he has a man in his
congregation who he notices is paying no
attention at all
and isn't really buying what the rabbi
is saying
and then the rabbi hums for the man a
yearning melody a bitter sweet melody
and the man listens and he says
now i understand what you've been trying
to tell me all this time because i'm
feeling this intense longing to be
united with god right
and i i read that i was like oh my god
you know i'm that old man yeah that's
that's you that you know that's leonard
cohen for you yeah right yeah and what
is it about that minor key
or that
musical sensibility
that elevates the soul and
can't help but leave you wondering
whether there is something more beyond
the senses yeah i think it's because
it's touching that
that sense that we all have of their
being
some other place that we're reaching for
you know you see it in
like the wizard of oz right it's like
dorothy's longing for somewhere over the
rainbow um you look at all our
children's stories there's always the
protagonists who enters the scene you
know at the moment they become an orphan
that that's when the whole adventure
begins like the moment they're thrust
into this state of primal longing
so
so i think that's just tapping into a
dna that we all share
although it manifests differently right
as you know there's a there's this idea
that you know this shared proclivity
towards their sweetness
allows us to understand that we are one
super organism
but perhaps
it it extends beyond the vagus nerve
right yeah you know right right you who
like you're exploring judaism and sufism
and these
various religions and and mystical
traditions
and there are similarities that they're
they're very different in many ways but
there are these similarities that unite
them
and from that
you know can one extrapolate you know
something some truth about the beyond or
our relationship with
something
more ethereal and non-material
yeah and i it's not like i
i don't know that exploring all this
gives you know definitive answers to any
of these lifelong questions but
for me it gave
it offers a kind of
roadmap of how to live you know because
what it does is it makes you notice how
incredibly
miraculous everything around us actually
is you know how sacred it really is
whether you're an atheist or believer
i'm just using those words like the
wonder of it all
um and you get into
you can enter into a relationship with
that kind of wonder yeah that really
it's a complete enhancement a really
transformation of what life is like
it's a better way to live it's a much
better way to
news is you can cultivate it in whatever
tradition suits you absolutely
absolutely there are so many paths
towards that
yeah we actually found you know in that
bittersweet quiz that we did that people
who score high in bitter sweetness also
score high in
states of awe and wonder
and spirituality
which is not it's not surprising it's
not surprising yeah right
so what is the relationship between
bittersweetness and on wonder there are
like two sides of a a similar coin
are they not yeah they are because um
they basically they're both born of um
a a receptivity and a noticing of
everything that is so you're not only
noticing one side of what is you know
you're like looking for the truth of
everything
and that's what gets you into that state
yeah i think when i think of on wonder i
think of being present like if you're
you if you're present enough and you
just see the leaf on the tree you know
that could inspire on wonder but it
requires like
a level of attention that that that kind
of eludes you know the way that we live
our lives right like you have to really
really be practiced in that or
habitual in it there's another parable
that i came across that i found
incredibly useful as a way to live
and this one also came from the kabbalah
and it's the idea that
all of creation was originally
this intact divine vessel it was all
intact and then it broke the the vessel
broke
and the world that we're living in now
is the world after the breakage
and yet the shards of this vessel are
scattered everywhere around us
and so what we can do we're still living
in the broken world but we're living in
a world where you can bend down and pick
up
these shards of light
and i love this as a way to live because
it's like a way of making sense of
the tragedies
that
are still and always part of this world
but yet being able to turn in the
direction of joy and beauty because
you're not denying the tragedies you're
not believing that a utopia is going to
come
but you're still able to bend down and
pick up the shards of light that you
personally notice and we're all going to
notice different ones
um but they're yours for the taking
yours to pick up yeah
that's really beautiful
but there's also packed into that a
little bit of a lament of what once was
or could have been had it not shattered
that's true
but i don't know i don't know a way to
live without that lament when you look
at the tragedies in the world like you
have to make space for the lament also
sure otherwise you're just living with
blinders i think yeah yeah
um is this
attunement to bittersweetness
trainable like you can take the
bittersweet test and see where you score
on it and certain people are obviously
more attuned or receptive to this than
others
but to the extent that appreciating
bittersweetness
or cultivating it or
or kind of synthesizing
all the different colors of your
experience into some kind of creative
offering and making sense of it for
yourself seems to be something that
anybody can do and you know even if they
score lower on that on that test
they could increase their score and and
perhaps like
um
you know elevate the written richness of
their life experience in in so doing
yeah so
there are going to be some people who
are born into the world with that high
sensitivity trait and they're probably
going to tend in this bittersweet
direction from the beginning then
there's going to be a lot of people who
just by virtue of life experience
come to more of a bittersweet awareness
over time right once
once things happen in their lives things
happen jar him out of their lack of
empathy or whatever it is right yeah
exactly exactly um and
for people who aren't there yet but
would want to be i i think it's just a
matter of
turning your awareness and your
direction i'm sorry turning your
awareness in certain directions
um
that's scary though
well it's scary if you think that by
doing that
you'll never come out again and that's
what i hear from a lot of people they're
like you know i'm afraid if i go there i
won't be able to come out mm-hmm
and
and yet there's no reason that that
should be so because
these two states are always paired right
it's joy and sorrow so there's no reason
you have to stay in one state it's more
just a sense of being able to tell the
truth about everything that's happening
or everything you observe yeah
why do you think it's scary um i mean i
just think you're asking people to
confront
painful past emotions or to look
objectively at stuff that they've kind
of worked hard to build walls around
right so that prospect of deconstructing
those walls and really grappling
with some past trauma or some something
that occurred or whatever that you've
kind of really tried hard to like move
away from
requires a a certain level of of courage
and i think it is frightening for a lot
of people like i know a lot of people
who have built walls around
certain you know
certain pains in their life and by dint
of that are able to kind of safely
navigate through their life but they
want to stay in that lane if you say
listen
you're missing a huge growth opportunity
or a certain level of of enriching life
experience by ignoring that you should
look at it and if you work through it
like your life is going to open up in
ways you can't possibly imagine
intellectually they may understand that
and i can kind of see
that arc
awaiting that person but for a lot of
people it's like that's fine i hear you
but i'm not going to do that
and you've had that i mean
your story about your mom in on a
certain level like illustrates this for
me like i i what i read in that was you
know a certain um
uh
kind of affect in your mother like she
had she had her own you know
painful experiences growing up and that
very much informed how she
interrelated with you at times in very
unhealthy ways but
could you have been able to get your
mother to kind of confront her past
traumas so that you could have had a
healthier relationship with her that
that seems like a very steep mountain
decline
yeah no i think people are at different
points along
where they are in their lives and
sometimes you're not ready at a certain
moment and you are 10 years later
um
and i guess another thing
yeah but sorry just to go back that's an
interesting question with my mom because
i've often thought you know
would there have been a way to
have her be open to that if i had
thought about how to
get there to do that and right yeah i
don't want to explain it a little bit
like tell a little bit of that story the
story yeah so um
so i had
a
really um intensely close relationship
with my mother growing up it was a kind
of garden of eden type of childhood
she was incredibly loving
devoted warm you know amazing company we
really loved each other's company
um
yeah it was really quite wondrous um
but but my mother had passed
traumas of her own and
this made it so that when i became an
adolescent she had a really
terrible time especially because i was
the youngest child she had a really
terrible time um with my growing up and
becoming independent and having
different ideas and different life
experiences
and um
and her reaction to that was
incredibly
difficult
to say the least um and
and i had a lot of trouble with it too
like i i felt like i i didn't use these
words in in those days but it was a kind
of like casting out of the garden of
eden like suddenly the mother that i had
known all my life had transformed into
a hostile
person um who where there was kind of a
choice i could either still be with her
and still be a child and be loved or i
could grow up and develop and be myself
and be cast out right and
and i don't think i ever really
questioned the choice so i went and
moved
in a separate direction
um
but the casting out part was like
incredibly
incredibly painful
and um and my way of dealing with it
because i'm a writer and
i'd loved writing since i was four years
old
i wrote everything down into these
diaries that i kept
and
went off to college and at the end of
freshman year
for some reason
i had to stay on campus for a few extra
days and my parents came to take my
stuff home
and just as they were getting ready to
leave
and they're like leaving with all my
suitcases
i take my diaries
and i hand them to my mother
and i thought at the time like i truly
on a conscious level i thought i was
just giving them to her for safekeeping
you know i didn't have a place to store
them at school
um
and i never thought that she would read
them on a conscious level
but of course she did and
whatever i had written there and i say
whatever because i've never read them
again since
but whatever i had written there you
know kind of like
put the final
nail in the coffin of our relationship
and so we we still
for the decades after we were still you
know seeing each other at holidays and
doing all the regular family stuff
but the relationship really was never
the same
again and it was like
it was a loss for me that
i couldn't for years i couldn't even
talk about my mother without crying i
couldn't mention her name
um
but i will say there's been this amazing
rapprochement
now my mother is alzheimer's
and
she's still she she only has a few
conversational liens that she can travel
but when she's on those lanes she still
feels like herself
and she has completely forgotten
all the difficult years we've we had
she's forgotten them and so
all this time through my adulthood i had
always been asking myself you know that
childhood that you remember
as being so wonderful like maybe it
wasn't really true you know maybe that
was just like
a child's misperception
but now
the mother of that childhood has come
back like i and i realized like we still
we still are that way you know that the
relationship we have now is the same
relationship we had when i was a kid
right um so that's been
that's been a kind of amazing
it's such an issue
and there it's certainly there's
bittersweetness in it oh yeah so much
um but the idea that you were faced with
this choice of either reverting into a
child-like state or just becoming the
person that
your mother actually wanted you to be
put you in an impossible situation
without her being consciously aware of
the kind of psychic
toll that that would place on you
and then the bitter sweetness of never
really fully reconciling that
later right i mean i i read it as
somebody who
because of her past traumas and pain
that she hadn't adequately worked
through there's this transference like
she wants you to be safe she wants you
to be upwardly mobile and all of these
things and she she lovingly drives you
um on this kind of ambitious journey to
achieving all these amazing things but
as you achieve them of course separation
occurs and that's a threat to this bond
that she has that is so meaningful
for her that is in part driven by
the pain of her past right that creates
this unhealthy soup where she's
transferring
so much of her identity onto you and
you're as a young person having to
shoulder that burden
yeah yeah and uh
yeah it's funny i'm actually gonna um
amend something i said before because
i think i said a minute ago that
i had never really considered doing
anything other than growing into a
separate person but actually i'm not
sure that's quite right because i do
remember many times saying to myself you
know
like i loved her so much
all i wanted was for her to be happy so
i felt like well maybe i should do some
of these things that she's asking you
know so that she can still be happy
um which is a very difficult thing right
yeah yeah yeah yeah
did you have a sense of her
self-awareness around any of this or
just no
i don't think so
yeah i don't really know um i don't
think there was so much of it
but
what i will say happened
excuse me over the years and especially
during the time i wrote this book you
know as i told you like it used to be
that i couldn't
talk about her at all without crying and
i i wrote her story i wrote the story in
the book
um
and i was like really worried about what
was going to happen when i would go out
and do
interviews about the book i thought i
won't be able to speak about this
without breaking down and
and despite everything i'm saying in the
book about being comfortable with all
our emotions i didn't really want to do
that right so
um so i didn't know what would
happen but
but i i i remember talking to somebody
about this dilemma and he said to me you
know talk to me when you're done writing
the book because you might actually
resolve
some of these issues and at the time he
said that i thought oh my gosh that's
never going to happen um
but in fact that's exactly what happened
there's just a sense of peace that
that i now have
with everything that happened
and i don't know just so much love for
her and understanding of it all
and like wishing that it had been
different but
excuse me
but um
i don't know it's just a complete
reconciliation well that's the that's
the beauty and the gift of reckoning
with your bitter sweetness right like
you can have some kinship with leonard
cohen who i'm sure similarly
was having you know uh conflicting
emotions and was in some sort of pain
and he was trying to work through it so
what does he do he writes a song about
it right you write a book about it and
in the process of writing this book you
find a way to heal and make peace with
yourself and your loved ones and come
out the other side like a more complete
human and that goes to the very thesis
of the book which is
channeling your pain
and and you know turning it into a
creative offering so it's like a it's a
it's like a a you know a meta exam like
it's all very meta in that yeah right
yeah yeah yeah no that's true um
and and i do want to be careful to say
like for anybody listening
again that we use that word creative in
a really general way so it's not like
you have to go and write a book or write
a song or you know like be a grammy
award winner or something it's not it
has nothing to do with that it's more
just about
going through a kind of transformation
of
like taking the pain and transforming it
into something of meaning yeah well just
confronting it and walking walking with
it and finding a way to
come to the other side through
whatever you know modality suits you
yeah it's funny i've been trying to
write this story for so many years like
i said this in the book i first started
writing about it when i was in college
and my creative writing teacher said
you're way too close to the story you
should like put it in a drawer and not
take it out again for 30 years
um
so it's been a long time and now it's 30
years later
but you're still so close to it
you know but you were you're you're
distant enough from it that you could
write about it with
some level of objectivity but the fact
that it that it
creates so much emotion in you you know
it's still very present with you
yeah it's still very present but like
with a lot less turmoil than there used
to be like
i experienced very little turmoil now
talking about it because i i really do
feel such a sense of resolution
between us and between like my
relationship to my mother in my heart is
very different yeah from what it had
been yeah beautiful yeah
um on this idea of of
of binaries
heaven hell
um
rich poor and the like
there is this undercurrent in our
society around around the pursuit of
happiness right it's in the it's in the
declaration of independence like the
pursuit of happiness and now we're in a
happiness-obsessed culture
um i think we're getting to a point
where we're we're maturely grappling
with what happiness means and trying to
create a healthier relationship with how
to build that into our lives but in
reading your book
i couldn't help but think
what would happen
if
that phrase in in the declaration of
independence said something like you
know may you may you uh you know pursue
longing or something like that may you
grapple with your own bitter sweetness
like if we had created a cultural
priority
around a more nuanced relationship with
the conflicting emotions
about what it means to be human how
would that percolate into our culture
and change our relationship with
the darker
side of things that you know make the
brighter things so much brighter
yeah it's an interesting question i've
thought about that with the declaration
of independence because i actually i
mean i enjoy being happy as much as the
next person so it's not so i don't think
happiness is the problem
but maybe it's just how we define happy
maybe meaning would happen is that the
cost of everything else yeah and i i
think we end up interpreting happiness
as a kind of like hedonic type of
happiness as opposed to a happiness
where you feel a deep sense of meaning
in your life
um
and i also think
part of the problem is that
we have such a separation of church and
state which is great in most ways but it
means that
all these
questions that religion naturally
grapples with
like this
existential longing that we all have
we tend to relegate that to what you
experience you know at church on sundays
as opposed to just thinking of that as
part of everyday life
um
yeah but as we become
more uh agnostic as a culture
are we not
uh adequately you know in in in
constructs where we are actively
confronted with grappling with these
philosophical questions and
wait say the question again is meaning
like
you're saying that the purview of that
kind of inquiry would be in the church
or whatever spiritual tradition but as
we've become kind of more we've become a
culture that's that seems at least from
my perspective like
less uh interested in
those types of uh
you know outlets
and so where does that leave us in terms
of of you know how we're dealing with
those bigger spiritual and philosophical
questions yeah that's the problem
because we've always relegated it just
to that so it was already bad enough
when it was relegated but now we don't
even go there so now it's kind of
nowhere you know dancing with the stars
is on and
yeah exactly so
i think we need to find ways of
introducing this into part of everyday
discourse and you could see how much we
long for it because you know you look at
to take my
patron saint of leonard cohen like
there's a reason that his song
hallelujah was
making people cry for years on end you
know it's like the most covered song i
think in history or something like that
um
people are relating to that as soon as
they hear it
they open up to it so we need to be
finding different ways of introducing
this into everyday life
um and i think part of that would
actually be just
kind of proactively engaging with beauty
more in everyday life you know like
at work at school like actively
encouraging people to bring in
things that they find beautiful or
meaningful and be sharing those you
don't even have to talk about
bittersweetness so much it's like
through through engaging with beauty all
of that comes out
how do you feel about jeff buckley's
rendition of halloween is that sacrilege
it's not sacrilege at all i i like it
it's not one of my favorites but yeah i
do really like it
okay but no i'm all for cover
he captures the bitter sweetness he sure
does music beautifully he really does
yeah i like the uh rufus wainwright one
oh yes very good yeah i'd forgotten
about that one
um
i think a good story to tell would be
the story of beethoven that you share
around that performance because that so
kind of captures this idea of
of you know channeling
channeling that emotional experience
into something shared yeah that that
that breeds that community piece right
yeah so beethoven you know one of his
maybe his most famous work is ode to joy
which everybody loves so much maybe we
could even play it somehow into the
episode yeah drop it in um
and
oh to joy actually started out as a poem
by frederick schiller and
beethoven loved this poem
because it expressed like all these
ideals of love and brotherhood that were
really important to him so he labored
for years i want to say it was 30 years
maybe getting that wrong but like
forever
to set this poem to music
but during the time that he's working on
it he starts to lose his hearing
and he has all these other personal
troubles
um and by the time
by the time of the debut performance
after all these years of creating ode to
joy
he's now totally deaf
and yet he's like desperate for
this music to be performed the way he
hears it in his head
and so he stands on stage with the
orchestra with his back turned to the
audience and he's facing the orchestra
and he's like throwing his body around
trying to direct them to play the music
the way he sees it in his mind he's
standing next to the conductor
um
and
because he doesn't see the because he
can't hear any of it he doesn't even
realize when the music is actually over
when they're done playing
but when it's finished
there's a 20 year old soprano and she
turns him around to face the audience
who are so overwhelmed they're like
standing up in their seats with tears
streaming down their faces and raising
their hands and tribute to this man
who's given them this experience of
longing which
you listen to that music and it's an ode
to joy it's literally about joy and yet
you can't help but hear
the longing and the sorrow that's like
echoing in its notes it's just the most
incredible that's what makes the music
so incredible
um and in fact
there is an economist at mit whose name
i'm forgetting right now but he did this
fascinating study where
he looked at mozart beethoven and liszt
at their music and he read all the
different letters they had written over
their lifetimes and he coded the letters
for emotions
and he found that during the periods
when they when their letters had a lot
of emotions expressed like sorrow and
longing and grief and like that that was
when they were composing their most
profound
best works of art wow yeah yeah
there's just this incredible confluence
there and i feel like we know it
instinctively yeah
but we're not sure what to do with it
and it's hard we don't want to go deaf
it's hard to like canonize it like oh
this note and this note it's more than
that right like it's the performance of
the music as well you have the story of
the the violinist right like when you
are carrying a certain emotional
resonance
it gets translated into those notes in a
certain way that we immediately
recognize but you can't quite define and
in telling that story about beethoven
it's very cinematic like i imagine like
he's just you know
like doing his thing with such you know
dramatic physicality
but because he can't hear he's
completely detached with how it's being
received
and perhaps even thinking like is this
even working at all or am i able to kind
of
get out of these musicians the
performance that i hear in my mind only
to find out that it is united and and
and really just you know uplifted and
connected this
this huge group of people and i think
it's really a profound example of
the power of of you know sharing
those types of emotions and and figuring
out a way to create a a container for it
that people can consume that really is
this antidote to what is dividing us and
it's like i don't have to tell you like
it does feel so divided out there and i
often despair of our ability to kind of
mend that division and it used to be
when a tragic event befell the country
or the world we would feel like one we
would feel like that super organism and
now it feels like when that happens
everybody retreats to their corner and
figures out how to blame the other side
for it and like how do we
move forward as a functional healthy
society
with this sort of
rift and
dynamic that doesn't seem to be going
away anytime soon
yeah i know and i mean i don't have
answers any more than anybody has
the answer but i do think that one thing
that we could and should be doing is
creating spaces for people to
truly be telling their stories
um
but to have the stories not be attached
to policy prescriptions or politics or
anything like that just tell each other
the stories you know like just get to
know each other on that elemental level
um
obviously like our social media
platforms right now are designed to do
the exact opposite of that but
sometimes like if we could have a social
media platform that would give people
space to just
share it all
maybe maybe it needs to be done
anonymously yeah something like that
yeah it is
sorry go ahead no i was just going to
say not everybody wants to tell their
story with a name attached the way you
do with the moth but
you know how there's a way to anonymize
it yeah yeah or or have that option
yeah i think there's something about
storytelling like honest open vulnerable
storytelling that is
akin to this notion of bittersweetness
and and perhaps it emanates from the
vagus nerve as well like when we hear
somebody share a story
and we have the sense that that story is
true to that person and honest and
authentically rendered
that also breeds connection right like
whether it's bittersweet or not like
just
the storytelling as a vehicle for
connection and also learning like
like it doesn't have to be prescriptive
but it's more effective than a
prescription when whatever that that
notion is is kind of wed into the
narrative like we as human beings are
able to kind of synthesize that
and then ultimately kind of uh hold on
to it and perhaps even practice it in
our lives in a way that
is very different than if somebody said
here's the five things that you need to
do today
we remember the story we forget the
listicle
um and i think there's something really
profound about that as well that that
perhaps you know can be traced back
evolutionarily you know back to the
the um
the campfires of
your and and the like absolutely i mean
i actually think podcasts play a huge
role in that
i think part of the reason that podcasts
have become the amazing medium that they
are is that they're
they're touching into that campfire
impulse that we have you know there's
something about the voice in your ear as
you're listening where you feel like
you're like bonded with all the other
listeners sitting around a campfire it's
connection exactly
exactly yeah so there you go there's
your there's your next book
what are you working on now are you on
another seven year jaunt to the next one
well i mean i probably will be at some
point and i have two different book
ideas that i'm playing with but i
actually want to start a podcast also so
i'm probably going to be doing that in
the next year
and that's going to be my next big
project
that's exciting can you say more about
that or is that under wraps right now
it's under wraps right now but i'll
definitely let you know
when it when it's ready it probably
won't be until 2023.
so so what do you what is it that that
you want
people to get out of
of bittersweet the most like if they're
if they're to take away you know one
core idea
um
i mean i guess i'd say the idea of that
whatever pain you can't get rid of to
make that your creative offering
um and then
and then another large idea i would say
and this applies to quiet as well as to
bittersweet
is
the idea of there being ways of being in
this world that are not
talked about that are actually kind of
hidden superpowers yeah um because i i
hear now from so many people like the
letters that i'm getting from people who
have read bittersweet
are so
similar to the letters i've gotten all
these years from quiet readers like it's
all these people saying you know i felt
this all my life and
either i never had words for it or i
never felt like it was okay to talk
about because it's not seen as the right
way to be
um and yet
and yet there is a sense of it being a
superpower once you understand it as
such yeah so
i think it would be helpful to also
share some words for
um perhaps the extroverts out there that
have introverts in their lives like
maybe they have a kid who's introverted
and they're struggling to understand
why this person you know wants to be in
their room and doesn't want to go to the
party or you know i think from a
parenting perspective i have an
introverted child a child is very
introverted and it's been an education
and a learning experience to like
like even though i have introverted
proclivities i still have some extra you
know sort of like i don't want to judge
my child because this is my child's
choice or this is what um you know this
person needs to you know recharge the
battery in terms of like how we parent
and how we think about supporting the
introverts in our life oh yeah i mean
there's so much to say there but i mean
the first thing as you're saying is to
just really understand like where your
child or spouse or whomever it is is
coming from and what do they need to be
happy
with children i think the fear often is
that if they're not kind of out there
socializing enough that they're not
gonna like get enough of the bounties
that life has to offer so one thing to
know is that like the the research shows
that if your child has one or two close
friends that's what they need like if
your kid has no friends at all that's
when you should be concerned
but if they have just a few friends and
if they're happy with that then that's
fine
um
and
to
i mean for all introverts there's the
question of if um
if a person wants to like stay home from
a party or something is that because of
a true preference of how they want to
spend their time or is it out of a sense
of fear or just comfort sure right and
like with with a child if you think it's
fear discomfort then that's when
you can be a really helpful parent in
helping them to develop strategies and
work through that but if it's just
preference of how they want to spend
their time then you want to make sure
they don't become too isolated but you
also want to honor their preference yeah
that becomes very nuanced and difficult
because
is it a preference or is it just you're
afraid of trying something new you need
to get pushed a little bit out into the
world and
and learn new things and try things and
fail and all of that to susan david's
point of emotional resilience like you
can't procure that in a vacuum
yeah and the answer to that like if you
sense that it's fear or discomfort
that's standing in the way
the answer to that for parenting but
also for our own selves is to
expose your child or yourself to the
thing that you fear but to do it in very
small steps so that it's manageable and
that your so your child has small wins
as they go so like a lot of introverted
kids just for example um
are a little iffy about swimming when
they're first introduced
and
the answer is not to like throw them in
the water
it's more to say okay let's go to the
pool on a day when it's super quiet
we'll go like late on a tuesday evening
and you're gonna dip your toe in the
water and that's it and then we're gonna
celebrate and we're gonna go home right
and then you go back the next day and
you do a little more and a little more
and a little more and little by little
they come to love it and then you can't
tell the difference between them and the
kid who just jumped in from the
beginning
but it's like
and
a lot of times introverted kids need a
longer runway that they travel down
before they take off and fly and they
need to know that you're with them on
the runway and admiring them and
respecting them
as they travel that runway right yeah
that's really good advice i like that um
the final thing i want to ask you about
is this idea of
of getting
being so good in your particular role
professionally
as an introvert but inevitably getting
promoted into a role that requires
extroversion which is the story of your
life right like
to write this book about introversion to
be an introvert and then to become the
public facing you know persona behind
this idea and this movement have foisted
you onto the public stage where now it's
kind of your job to like
be extroverted in public right and
having to kind of learn a new set of
skills
and i think it's common probably in in
you know less extreme examples of
people who excel at their job and then
suddenly they get promoted into a role
that requires a completely different
skill set that that is at odds with
who they want to be or what they're good
at
yeah okay so i mean the first thing i
would say is that
when that happens
that's really the moment when you know
whether you
love and care about your work or not
because it's one thing
to have to go outside your comfort zone
in the service of work that you love
and it's another thing to have to do it
for a job that you don't actually care
about that much
so like i'm really like i i care so much
about what i'm doing and i love writing
so much and these ideas that it's like
worth it to me
to go through the
the parts that are more
more of a stretch
um
so in some ways the introverts can see
that as an advantage that they're less
likely to get stuck in the wrong job
because it's just going to be too
painful at the end of the day when they
get promoted um
[Music]
but also
so the psychologist brian little talks
about this a lot the idea that
in this service of work or people we
care about
we can and do and should sometimes step
out of character
but
you have to do it in a way that honors
your own self and you have to give
yourself lots of restorative niches to
come back
so
like i do that all the time like when i
go out on
trips and i'm giving talks or interviews
or whatever i spend so much time
afterwards ordering room service and
just like chilling in the hotel
yeah yeah yeah it's like you can't wait
to get back to the hotel room and be
alone
yes yeah yeah and i really like honor
that time um and i guard it really
carefully
um and then i also you know
i feel like i'm lucky because i also get
to spend a lot of time
doing my work it's just like sitting at
a cafe writing right so
i i do think it's worth asking oneself
like if you get to a point where your
work is having you constantly doing
things that are outside your comfort
zone
it might be the wrong place for you
but if you can get it to a manageable
place and it's in the service of
something you care about then it's okay
yeah if if you're
if you being like the this public-facing
person on the subject of bittersweetness
or introversion met meant that
um you couldn't write anymore because
now you're running a large organization
that's trying to foster these ideas that
probably would not be something you
would want that would be
too high of a cost way too high even if
it would make you super successful and
push these initiatives through and
change the world it's not
within your constitution to do so yeah
and having that self-awareness to
recognize that exactly exactly yeah not
your constant not i feel like it's not
my constitution it's not my calling it's
not what i feel like i should be doing
um
yeah but you know i am super careful
about that when i
when i go and do these public-facing
things and is it is it non-anxiety
producing for you now because you're so
practiced at it
so it's not like extremely
anxiety-producing anymore the way it
used to be for me um really not at all i
feel like i've overcome that but i would
still say that you know
a morning in which i am looking at a day
full of publicity versus a morning where
i'm looking at a day full of writing
with my laptop
those are completely different mornings
yeah two different experiences yeah i
don't know maybe everybody feels that
way um but
i feel like it's probably more intense
the difference between those two is
probably more intense for me right like
i think i read actually that you
am i right about this that you spend
your mornings doing exercise and
writing and contemplative things the
first part of the day yeah yeah and then
you do podcast interviews and things
like that later right and when i read
that i thought that's really interesting
i don't think that would work for me
because
if i knew that i had the
public facing side
happening later in the day i don't know
that i would be able to
enjoy as much
their writing contemplative stuff spoils
the other stuff earlier in the day yeah
yeah that makes sense but it sounds like
you don't experience that um
no it it definitely
like public speaking creates a lot of
anxiety for me um
but like doing podcasts less so
um and it's something i i you know i
could do it in the morning too but i
just i need that time for that's that's
a that's a recharge the battery time
right like if i don't recharge the
battery
then when i come in to do this other
stuff like i'm just not at my best so i
have to protect that
time for self-care and that doesn't mean
that i always do it perfectly or that i
don't make exceptions because life
intervenes and all of that but i try
really hard to like
that's that's how i preserve
you know who i am
the whole thing and it's a privilege not
everybody can have that right absolutely
i recognize that um
but it's pretty fundamental to
kind of how i do things yeah i know that
makes sense
um and i have my my uh you'll appreciate
this like my home office
um
is a shipping container uh that we
kitted out into like an office so it's
just like a writing office with
bookshelves and things like that and
that's where i kind of can work at home
so it's customized on the inside and you
know has an air conditioner and all that
kind of stuff but it's literally a
shipping container right and when and
and
when we were kind of figuring out how to
tweak it and customize it
um the kind of contractor that we hired
to like help us with this he's like well
you're gonna want a big window and you
should do and it should be like this let
all the sunlight in i was like no i
don't want any window like i wanted to
be like i literally want to have the
experience of being in the womb
like on some level on a primal level
like that's what makes me feel safe and
protected yeah i know i totally
understand and then he still put a
little window in and then i hung a shade
over it and so i could black it out
anyway
i hope that office designers are
listening to that
because they're all like you're crazy
you're gonna want this i'm like i'm
telling you i'm not going to want it all
right well any last thoughts for the
introverts out there grappling with
bittersweetness
before we wrap it up
yeah i think we can wrap it up
really just to
understand um
i don't know just that my view of life i
don't know if i've said this already so
edit this out if i have but um lay down
the truth
my life philosophy is that there are
different kinds of superpowers that
exist in this world and usually we're
each only granted one or two of them you
know like we know this from all the
movies right there's like lightsabers
and
and then there's like spider-man and
incredible hulks and all these different
ways of being powerful in the world
and so for people who are born with more
of a
a bittersweet way of being or an
introverted way of being in a sensitive
way of being these are these are super
powers
that
where you're like in the stage of the
movie you're like luke skywalker before
he knows that he has the force basically
because your culture isn't teaching you
about the superpower that you naturally
possess
but it's there
it's just yours to discover
i think there's something really
powerful too about
that quiet person who is really grounded
there's a center of gravity and kind of
an anchor to that person who knows who
he or she is yeah um and is really
comfortable in that quiet space
that is
perhaps exponentially more powerful than
the boisterous person who's you know
really loud and perhaps charismatic
but
unable to kind of um
have the resonance that you know that
that quiet powerful person
yeah i think that's right and like i
often tell people you know
because people are
quieter people are always concerned
about how do you show up in a meeting
and still have presence especially when
everybody's you know talking being very
dominant um
but there's a way
where if you're speaking from a sense of
conviction
people know it like they feel it right
away and that's what carries the power
so
the answer is not to try to become a
louder more dominant person the answer
is more to get in the habit of
understanding what you truly believe and
speak what you truly believe and then
people feel that
that's where the power comes from there
you go
beautiful
um
thank you thank you now i appreciate it
uh the work that you do
and the wisdom that you share with the
world is is really powerful and it's
obviously changing millions and millions
of people's lives and
um
i think these are really important
topics and subjects
um that previously perhaps we were too
afraid to talk about and you've made it
a thing and i just wanted to publicly
thank you for that and can't we just say
see what you do next well thank you so
much and such a treat to get to meet you
in person and i just love the work you
do so thank you thank you pleasure and
the honor is mine so come and talk to me
again sometime i would love it cool
peace
[Music]
you